why do you keep ripping off the poor
guy's right arm we don't need it
you've seen me play surgeon simulator
one before
now it's time for the brand new one that
just came out surgeon simulator two but
i need my handy side kick welcome bianca
anti sarah to the channel
the pro gamer the real life nurse what's
up thank you so much for having me i am
so excited to play certain simulator 2.
this is going to be awesome it has been
a very long time since i have been in
the or
but i know we're going to destroy it
we're gonna be like the dream team
are you ready to come on to the terminal
with me i brought you a cake
there you go come oh thank you oh okay
that's what i think of that cake we're
in we're in
uh the diagnostic thing says heart does
that mean we have to get the heart
yes okay i'm gonna slam him with this
fire extinguisher
okay can you get the ribs out of the way
that i break yes
did i break any off you did oh we got
the arm the arm's off
wait why'd you take the arm off it's
just supposed to be his heart how can i
get the heart without getting the lung
you're a little oh i got the oh no i got
i took the lung out
i got his heart where does it go oh god
where does the heart go
we need a new heart i don't know where
to put it level failed the patient lost
too much blood
ready i'm gonna start breaking his ribs
okay let's go
three two one breaking ribs
okay we got one okay let's get the get
the heart let's go
i got the heart we need blood or we need
the stop bleeding medicine i'm giving
him the stop bleeding medicine first i
got blood syringe
oh no i cut his arm off oh my god he's
losing blood fast
i'm getting another vial no why is he
losing oh i got to put the arm back on
come on okay i put his arm back on are
you getting another blood syringe yes
i'm giving him the stop bleeding
medicine
we left the tool in there let me get the
tool out of here okay
did we find the new heart yet maybe oh i
cut his leg off
where is that i put it back on i put it
back on not to worry i put it back on
okay here we go
i have organs here what organ do we need
heart yes
i see a lot of organs but no heart if i
was a heart
where would i be oh i think i found an
organ oh i found the heart there we go
there's the heart i got the heart okay
let's go
and this is serious we've come so far
drop it in there yay
high five high five high five
we heal we only six minutes
let's go round two there's no eye in
team wait did it start already
oh no what are you doing sick arms okay
i'm pulling off the right arm you pull
off the left arm
okay i ripped off his arm where does it
go where does it go
oh we have to do one arm at a time i
almost feel like we're not medical
professionals bianca
okay which arm are we doing first let's
do right arm because it's further away
from the heart
okay you do that i'm gonna get i'm gonna
get the thing to stop the blood uh the
arm
this is the left arm right now i have
the right arm
oh no it dropped okay i'll keep them
stabilized so you get back
i don't understand i have to put this
arm somewhere i don't even know where
do you see a place where i can put the
arm i see where it goes but we're locked
out of it you do
where yeah if you come back into the
suite oh i'm in the bathroom okay i mean
it's back here maybe there's like a way
to break in there or something
oh wait i see what we need to do we need
to throw something
up there what if you push this box and
then i'll jump on it
you can do it oh you're so good
okay okay i did it okay i found a
healthy right arm
i'm coming i'm coming okay right arm is
on
let's get the left arm all right the arm
is off i'm
i'm delivering it i'm stopping the
bleeding
okay i got the left arm i'm coming in
with the left arm
no come on there you go
i have to rip off an arm in order to get
in here can i borrow your arm
take it i can't i don't think it's your
arm that i need okay
what arm do you need do you need a right
arm or a left arm yeah it's a right arm
okay
okay i'm bringing it oh it worked
like a hot dog aha man don't mind if i
do
all right left arm right leg i'm
starting off with the left arm
all right the right arm is off okay we
have a problem look where the arm is
i can't get it out oh no i know
wait bianca try and press this button
that i'm looking at
thank you okay i have a healthy left arm
for you
bringing it in now oh my gosh i'm
bringing blood so fast
i have no i have the arm i have the arm
i i put the arm back on
okay so when i pull the arm off you have
to go right away with the syringe
i got you there you go okay i'm ripped i
ripped off his arm open the door for me
quick
okay there we go i'm stopping the
bleeding okay
bleeding is stopped okay i'm bringing
the left arm in why won't the armory
attach b
i don't know oh i got it on okay did you
rip off the leg
no it's the wrong leg you have the leg
not me i got the syringe
okay i'm going to get the other leg out
okay i got the blood
don't panic don't panic stay calm stay
calm i hope this is not how you run
codes in the er
oh my god his arm popped off no put it
back on
oh my god we're gonna fail b why did you
i put his leg back
b okay i got the arm all right i'm
running to you now
this is it i got faith in this one i'm
on the way back
with the right leg wait why is his right
arm off
oh my god b put his right arm back on me
why do you keep ripping off the poor
guy's right arm we don't need it
okay i've transferred the leg for a
healthy leg i'm stopping bleeding
very gently we have not no limbs at this
moment
no limbs what do you mean there's no
light i mean no no removed other than
the ones that are necessary so i'm gonna
pop in the right leg right now boom we
saved them
why isn't it not completed healthy oh we
need to take out
his appendix what or whatever that blue
thing is in the middle
his into small intestine i guess i'll do
that just keep them alive just stabilize
them
you got this you got it perfect i took
it off where do i go with it i have
no idea i'm stopping the bleeding best
wishes on your journey
oh i found it i'm running back
oh no it fell oh
yeah good job
look at that dance all right let's beat
this and call
ourselves surgical simulation champions
how do you feel about these dance moves
right now oh look what i found wow
dancing pays off what do we have to do
there's this place with the
looks like intestines just like hanging
out there we got rib pieces back here
that we can't get into
oh yeah but what is this thingy here
looks like we gotta put some battery
oh i see a vent
[Music]
oh i'm in i'm in it i got it i got an
electric
thing we might need it later
all right now we can go into the organ
room okay good now that we've set this
up let's start our operation you ready
yes you know what i don't see any
syringes here forget syringes i don't
know what we're doing here oh yeah we
don't even have a screen to tell us
what's sick
there's another one here let's see
there's another little vent we didn't
move
yeah oh we need another battery to open
up this
red thing here i guess this is where
we're gonna get our syringes
i need my syringes get them
oh wow but i don't know what surgery
we're doing on him when in doubt replace
everything okay i'm gonna start
replacing stuff you ready all right
bring it on
commencing rib removal okay ribs are
removed
now we need to wait why did you rip his
arm off put his arm back on
i took out his lung no
do you really think that we have to
replace everything
i don't know all right we need to do his
heart
stomach and right leg okay let's do his
right leg first
okay left legs off stopping the bleeding
gingerly
okay leg is on oh my gosh the syringe is
not wanting to cooperate with me
there we go got this i have faith in you
yeah
now i'm gonna get his heart but in order
to get his heart i'm gonna have to break
his ribs ready
yeah there we go
oh i took his stomach okay i'm gonna get
his stomach
okay oh that's a small intestine that's
the wrong thing
okay got his heart out where's the heart
i see lungs
i see a heart all right the heart is in
i'm going in for the stomach
okay i got i got whatever it is out i
got his stomach out
that's the intestine that's the ribs you
can do it uh
that looks like a stomach that kind of
looks like a stomach i'm coming in with
a stomach
this should be his last thing oh no i
dropped it
oh we did it good job
that one was legit tough
because you did a great job stabilizing
him though you did awesome
you're like a super spy super spy
surgeon like in vince and stuff like
that
ripping off people's limbs yeah i think
we've officially made ourselves
the surgeon simulator two champions i
think we did good
i think we did we did very good honestly
it's just as chaotic as the
true operating room would be yes trying
to find limbs
cakes hot dogs going through vents
ripping off limbs bianca and i actually
played another game before of would you
rather
dr nurse playing would you rather that's
a good watch click here to check it out
and as always stay happy and healthy